3.3 million veterans and Counting have
served since 9/11 around three million
have decided to pursue higher education
degrees research from CU NY shows that
post 9/11 vets perform above the
national average in most socio-economic
categories between 2005 and 2015 they
had higher employment rates with median
household incomes higher than the
national average however over half of
employers believe that veterans don't
pursue a college or vocational degree
and that veterans don't have successful
careers after the military the media and
public erroneously believe that the
majority of post 9/11 vets have a mental
health disorder unfortunately since
government-funded research prioritizes
PTSD and since the Rippon Durance a well
intentioned veteran legislation
emphasizes mental health disorders the
public potential employers and veterans
themselves are trapped in the inaccurate
and harmful broken veteran narrative
this matters in an all-volunteer force
reputation is key to the attractiveness
of joining up professions how we
publicly portray veterans relates to how
society conceptualizes military service
veterans are the unacknowledged
permanent ambassadors of national
service do you think our veterans are
misrepresented today in media and
culture why or why not let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI